les plus observateurs l'auront sûrement
remarqué des bateaux écoles navigue
désormais sur le lac de l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines se former
au permis bateau sur place c'est donc
maintenant possible si la pratique est
dispensée sur un lac
les contraintes sont presque les mêmes
que celles en mer il y avait quand même
des conditions de mer aujourd'hui avec
le levant qu'on avait le début de
petites vagues au programme de la partie
pratique les manoeuvres à connaître pour
piloter un bateau à moteur mais aussi
l'apprentissage du matériel et des
responsabilités en tant que chef de bord
dont quelques matériel obligatoire à
avoir à bord
autour autant pour la segard en tire la
sécurité individuelle que la sécurité
collective et ensuite en fait c'était de
la manoeuvre la gestion à haute vitesse
pouvoir gérer des virages à haute
vitesse pour voir gérer un arrivée de
ponte ont repêché un homme à la mer
prendre un coffre ces nouveaux points
d'enseignement pratique permet d'élargir
l'accessibilité on a décidé en fait de
séquencer les formations sur l'année on
va essayer de faire six mois sur la
marne donc six mois plus vers l'est de
paris et le six autres mois plus vers
l'ouest de paris afin de pouvoir
favoriser tous les clubs qui veulent
avoir accès à cette formation organisée
par nautisme en ile-de-france et la
formation au permis bateau s'effectue
sur trois jours après validation de la
partie pratique les candidats doivent
passer l'épreuve théorique on aura accès
à un service informatique on pourra
répondre à tout un tas de questions qui
nous seront tous et des qcm des choses
comme ça et après on sera convoquée pour
passer officiellement le permis cet
enseignement est réservé aux licenciés
des clubs franciliens issus des quatre
ligues voile kayak aviron et ski
nautique